day 16 10 or 9 p.m. this is the best
part the woman that is giving us the
apartment was engaged to be married and
the engagement has since been canceled
you know she wants to get the [ __ ] out
of her place she like hates being in her
apartment all of her furniture which is
still there will be staying with us
because a reminder of her ex-fiance
so she's selling it to us for like 600
always less than it's worth
found relationships for the wedding but
he most likely cheating on you and you
caught him in the bed that you're giving
us oh I want I have no money
Jimmy great financial funds bad credit
history I didn't pay my taxes last year
this is what sold me all of a sudden she
was like and this coffee maker that has
two little cups that the coffee goes to
do and I looked at it I looked at grace
I was like those could have been your
two little cups after you've been
recently married and just come back for
your wonderful honeymoon here's your
coffee let's get on the subway together
no I wonder what happened between them I
don't care that much neither do I